in summary section 230 says that
platforms cannot be held liable for user
generated content as long as it's lawful
speech and
that has given them a lot of ability to
grow because it would be pretty much
impossible to run a social network if
you had to be constantly checking
everything that someone posted to make
sure it's not defaming somebody or you
know making some sort of uh uh you know
comment that someone's going to sue you
the provider over and that is uh some so
it's essential to the existence of these
platforms and it's something that Biden
and his team uh over this time period
has consistently and continually said
they want to take a look at and they
have said it under circumstances where
it's quite close to where they're
talking about they don't like the
behavior they these platforms are
engaging in or what they're allowing to
proliferate so let's start with a clip
of candidate Biden in January 2020
uh saying this to the New York Times
editorial board
Mr Vice President in October your
campaign sent a letter to Facebook
regarding an ad that falsely claimed
that you blackmailed Ukrainian officials
to not investigate your son and I'm
curious did that experience dealing with
Facebook and
their power did that change the way that
you see the power of tech platforms
right now no I've never been a fan of
Facebook as you probably know I've never
been a big Zuckerberg fan I think he's a
real problem
them being exempt which you're not
exempt you can't write something you're
knowing to be false and being exempt
from being sued but he can't section 230
should be revoked immediately should be
revoked number one for Zuckerberg and
other platforms that's a pretty
foundational love of the modern that's
right it's internet exactly right and it
should be revoked
it should be revoked
because it is not merely an internet
company it is propagating falsehoods
they know to be false and we should be
setting standards not unlike the
Europeans are doing it relative to
privacy you guys still have editors I'm
sitting with them not a joke there is no
editorial impact at all on Facebook none
none whatsoever it's irresponsible it's
totally irresponsible if if there's
proven harm that that Facebook has done
should someone like Mark Zuckerberg be
uh submitted to criminal penalties
perhaps
he should be submitted to civil
liability in his company to civil
liability just like you would be
here at the New York Times
so there's uh Biden coming in hot
Zuckerberg that has a real problem uh
and then once he got in office I've got
two clips from his press secretary that
I want to play in succession uh the
first is uh from around that same time
period uh when uh yes from jensaki it's
from around that same uh time period uh
that the Murthy statement came out so
let's play that one first
uh jensaki really likes uh section 230.
the president's view is that
um the major platforms uh have a
responsibility related to the health and
safety of all Americans uh to stop
amplifying untrustworthy content
disinformation and misinformation
especially related to covid-19
vaccinations and elections and we've
seen that over the past several months
broadly speaking I'm not placing any
blame on any individual or group we've
seen it from a number of sources he also
supports better privacy protections and
a robust Anti-Trust program so his view
is that there's more that needs to be
done to ensure that this type of
misinformation disinformation damaging
sometimes life-threatening information
is not going out to the American public
okay and so there she is uh that was in
May 2021 uh saying that you know we have
a real problem with the kind of
information they're letting flourish it
would be a shame if we took a look at
section 230 and also some Anti-Trust
action that's really at the front of our
minds uh strangely in 2022 that same
pair came up after uh Elon Musk
purchased Twitter and said that he
wasn't going to be suppressing that sort
of information anymore let's play that
clip for a moment
breaking news Twitter agreeing to let
Elon Musk uh purchase make this go
through this purchase do you have a
response to that and does the White
House have any concern that this new
agreement might have President Trump
back on the platform well I'm not going
to comment on a specific transaction uh
what I can tell you is a general matter
no matter who owns or runs uh Twitter uh
the president has long been concerned
about the power of large social media
platforms uh what they have that power
they have over our everyday lives has
long argued that Tech platforms must be
held accountable for the harms they
cause he's been a strong supporter of
fundamental reforms to achieve that goal
including reforms to section 230
enacting Anti-Trust reforms requiring
more transparency and more and he's
encouraged that there's bipartisan
interest in Congress
so
clearly there's it's like a reflex
whenever we're talking about
misinformation we're gonna bring up you
know this threat of section 230 reform
and Anti-Trust I guess my question for
you John is is that really illegal
though or is that just kind of using the
bully pulpit in a way that's First
Amendment protected
does it abridge speech I think it does I
think that you're bringing to bear this
is worth billions 230 is worth billions
to these companies and the fact that
there's bipartisan anger over it and I'd
never seen that clip of Biden you just
ran
um that is that is even more explicit uh
maybe it'll be in my next brief but I I
think that I think that uh what what you
have here is it's it's a threat to take
away billions of dollars from these
corporations and to change their whole
way they work and even if you can't get
Congress go along here you can then you
can have Republicans in those clips on
230 by the way as well and um but the
administration itself can take positions
it can have the justice department take
a position that 230 doesn't cover this
or 230 doesn't cover that that's a huge
headache for these so you don't even
need to pass legislation so it's it's a
it's a huge threat as they as as the
fifth circuit judges were asking you
know nice social media company you have
there shame if anything things gonna
happen to it and I so I think that it is
when you look at this whole of
government and the whole of the threat
this is not a one-off this is not you
know uh JFK calling in the steel guys
and saying you know steel prices are a
little high can you guys watch it or
something one time this is the
administration contacting them every day
every week constantly
so then would your argument be then that
they should just never be able to make
those sort of statements that these are
actually kind of illegal veiled threats
so uh the the argument is is that a
first of all this doesn't cover Biden
right the the courts are not going to
tell the president what to say or not
say so Biden would still say what he's
going to say on your clips and and
that'll go in but but that can then be
used that the agencies are doing this
that or the other thing for this reason
yeah but yes the fact that they're
contacting these com these companies to
tell them who to keep on and who to keep
off is the problem not that they have
their own views you know we depose the
CDC I don't know what's going to come
out about the census but they got these
portals into all the um social media
companies during the census the census
wanted to get its message out to
communities that were afraid of the
sense is coming there so they'd say look
we don't do this we don't do immigration
we don't do all these things and the
social media platforms gave them these
portals so that they could get their
messages out onto the portals and and
and learn how to get it higher up that
wasn't a problem we have never heard
that the Census Bureau had people take
down don't answer the door you know
um but it was then metastasized when
covet came along and this this portal
and this idea of hey we don't really
know much about social media how do we
get our message out there turn to how do
we stop these people's messages and
that's the problem when they're saying I
don't like this message take it down
that's what's that's what the problem is
hey thanks for watching that clip from
my conversation with Jay bhattacharya
and John vecchione about Missouri V
Biden a very important legal case about
the future of social media and free
speech for another clip from that click
here for the full conversation click
here